وصف زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي في مقابله حصريه اجرتها زميله
العنود العبدلي وصف العلاقه بين الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه بانها قويه للغايه وان
البلدان حليفان في قضايا عده
[موسيقى]
حول الملف النووي الايرانيه كد زعيم
الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
للعربيه ان واشنطن تبذل كل الجهد لمنع
ايران من امتلاك سلاح النوويشن
[موسيقى]
يقول بان الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
قريبونا
قريبين من بعضهم البعض بشتى الاوجه عمليا
اليوم
هل هذه العلاقه في شكلها في اطارها الصحيح
الذي يتحدث عنه ام هو يتحدث عن المرحله
التي الطويله التحالف الطويل منذ 80 عاما
وهي التي يجب ان تكون بها كذا شكل اظن ما
يعني ما ذكره الزعيم الاقليه في مجلس
الشيوخ هو يعبر عن قناعه ثابته في واشنطن
تجاه العلاقه مع المملكه
وقيمتها الاستراتيجيه الهاميه
الاستراتيجيه للمملكه وان كان مر يعني
احيانا من وقت لاخر تمر بعض الاحداث
والمؤثرات اللي ممكن تعطي انطباعا مختلفا
لكن هناك الان تحول حقيقه او عوده ما يمكن
اسميه عوده الوعي لواشنطن
بادراك واهميه العلاقه مع مع مع المملكه
كونها شريك استراتيجي لعلك لاحظت يعني
تحول فيه في خطاب الاداره الامريكيه
وتوجهها
بعد زياره الرئيس بايدن للمملكه والقيمه
اللي عقدها يعني الخطاب اختلف تماما وكان
هناك حديث وجدل كبير جدا داخل الاداره
الامريكيه وخارجها في
حتى في الكونجرس حول اهميه العلاقه
واعادتها الى مسارها الطبيعي بلا شك
العلاقه يعني لها جذورات تاريخيه ولها
هناك ملفات مشتركه بين المملكه وبين
الولايات المتحده يعني ابرز هذه الملفات
اللي هي الملف الموضوع الاستقرار في
المنطقه
العسكريه والسياسيه
بعد الثنائي بلا شك مهم جدا لكن في شيء
العلاقات بحكم اهميه المملكه المملكه
اليوم هي قوه اقليميه يعني تستطيع تعتمد
عليها في يعني ضمان او
مهدد في المنطقه دكتور وهو ما تحدث قبلك
قبل قليل طبعا في يعني هذه المقابله
ما الذي يعنيه بالنسبه لنا في الخليج
عندما يقول ميتشمكونل بان الاتفاق النووي
مع ايران قد نهار
هل بدائل الاتفاق النووي اليوم مفيده لدول
المنطقه دول الخليج تحديدا او حتى ممكن
القول بانها عمليه اكثر من الدبلوماسيه
التي تردد في واشنطن دائما بانها الحل
الافضل للتعامل مع البرنامج النووي
الايراني هو البدائل ما هي البدائل اما
الاتفاق او تصعيد لانه فيه قوى لن تسمح
بتحديدا اسرائيل واضحه في طرحها لن تسمح
بوصوح وصول يعني ايراني تحول الى قوه يعني
نوويه او استمرار ايران في برنامج وهي
مستمره الان
الان لو قست هاي البدائل يعني من ناحيه
يعني
مصلحه المنطقه ككل وليس فقط الخليج البديل
الانسب هو الاتفاق والدول الخليج والمملكه
في مقدمتها يعني ما هي معترضه تماما عن
الاتفاق هي ترى الاتفاق لكن ترى الاتفاق
جديد يضمن ان لا تتحول ايران الى قوه
نوويه لاننا ندرك من خلال سلوكها خلال
اربعين سنه انه هذه القوه النوويه لو
تحولت حصلت على قدره النوويه انها لن تكون
يعني تفتح يعني باب
لعدم حاله من عدم الاستقطاء يعني
الاستقرار في المنطقه وتصعيد خطير جدا
فنحن نقول يعني بالنسبه يعني الاتفاق انه
يكون شامل طبعا هو الجانب الناحيه
الرقابيه دقيق جدا لكن في جزئتين الجزئيه
الاولى هذه الملاحظه القويه على الاتفاق
اولا انه لا يشمل يعني البرنامج الصواريخ
بلاستيه هذا يعني جزء كبير مهم جدا لابد
يشماله اتفاق النقطه الثانيه ان لا تعطى
فرصه يعني بمعنى ارتفاق السابق كان يعطيها
فتره معينه وبعدها يتيح ايران تطوير يعني
قدرات النوويه نحن نريد اتفاقا يضمن لاننا
همنا هي استقرار في هذه المنطقه
والحديث عن الولايات المتحده فقط نتوقف
لمتابعه هذه الصور دكتور صالح للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن في اجتماع ثنائي مع
الرئيس البولندي ثم نعود نستمع
ذلك ازمه انسانيه
وبالتالي
فان هذا ادى الى الماء ماساه فيرار
المواطنين من منازلهم بسبب عمليه القصف
والجرائم المروعه التي ارتكبت
على ايدي الجنود الروس
ولكن شكرا جزيلا مره اخرى السيده الرئيس
على زيارتكم لان هذا دليل كبير على ان
العالم الحر لم ينسى هؤلاء المواطنين
السيد الرئيس ادرك مدى الشجاعه التي
يتطلبها الامر اتصور ان الامر لم يكن سهل
الاسيه بالنسبه لاولئك المسؤولين على
امنكم السيده الرئيس ارجو ان تنقل لهم
تقديري لجهودهم
شكرا لك سيد الرئيس على هذا القرار نحن
سعداء ان نستضيفكم في بولندا
وسوف نلتقي غدا مع حلفائنا في الجناح
الشرقي للنيت لان هذه الزياره رمزيه ومهمه
جدا بالنسبه لنا جميع نحن ننظر اليها ليس
كزيار الى بولندا وانما هي زياره الى
الاقليم والى كييف وهي تبعث برساله قويه
رساله مسؤوليه الولايات المتحده
تجاه امني اوروبا والعالم الولايات
المتحده التي اثبتت مرارا وتكرارا مسويتها
تجاهها اوروبا كما حدث خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وكذلك الحرب البارده في
كل مره
عملت الولايات المتحده على استعاده
الحكم القانون
النظام الديمقراطي واستطاعت شعوب انت
السعيده حريتها بعد عشرات السنين كما حدث
في بولنديه وذلك بفضل التضامن وكذلك تصميم
الشعب البولندي
وكذلك الضغط الذي مارسه الراحل البابا فول
الثاني ونحن نقدر هذا الموقف ونقدر موقف
رئيس ريجن ايضا
وفي النهايه فان
الامبراطوريه الشر انهارت وانهار ايضا
فيدار برلين
وانتصرنا معا
ونحن نعتقد بان امريكا قادره على الحفاظ
على النظام الدولي
وصونه وان تظهر لكل المعتدين الذين يريدون
تدمير حياه غيري هم وسيطر على بلدان اخرى
واستعبادها ايضا
الولايات المتحده تثبت بانه لا يمكن
للديمقراطيات وممثله
ان تتقبل سلوكا كهذا
شكرا لكم على ذلك كما قلت هذا دليل كبير
بالنسبه لنا نحن في اوكرانيا ولشعب
الاوكرانيا
هذه الزياره نحن السيد الرئيس سعداء بان
هناك رساله قويه تبعثون بها منهن للعالم
باسره والعالم كله سوف ينظر الى هذه
الزياره ونحن سعداء جدا بها وهذا يثبت
ايضا
مدى اهميه الاهميه بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده الوضع في اوروبا وكذلك بالنسبه
لنا هذا تاكيد باننا نقوم بالامر الصحيح
وما قمنا به مؤخرا من اجراءات في دعم
اوكرانيا من خلال ارسال الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا ومساعدتي الاوكرانيين ودعمهم
بسته سبل
هذا دليل بان هذا هو سبيل الصحيح وهذا
دليل باننا نحظى بدعم الولايات المتحده
نريد ان ندعم ايضا جيراننا ونحاول ان نقوم
بكل ما هو ضروري لتامين اوروبا ونحن لا
ننتظر فقط
المتحده وانما نقدم هذه الضمانات الامنيه
ايضا لجيراننا ودول البلطيق وكذلك
لرومانيا حيث ينتشر جنود النيتو
هناك ايضا جنود
بولنديون
وبكل بساطه نريد ان نظهر التضامن فيما بين
الحلفاء
والسيد الرئيس شكرا مره اخرى على القيام
بهذه الزياره الى بولندا نحن نرى او نحن
مقتنعون بان الشعب البولندي ينظر في هذه
الزياره دعم
لتحالفنا وقد حضينا بهذه الفرصه
لاستضافتكم هنا السيد الرئيس وهذا ايضا
يمثل اشاره قويه للمستثمرين في الغرب
السيد الرئيس هذا يثبت تناولندا بلد امن
ويمكن
للانسان ان يزوره من اي مكان كان على وجه
هذه المعموره هولندا بلد امن بفضل تواجد
القوات الامريكيه وكذلك قوات النيتو وبفضل
ايضا الجهود التي نبذلها لدعم امن بولندا
وقدرتها الدفاعيه
ونحن سعداء السيد الرئيس للنازيره
دعم قوي لهذا التواجد
الامريكي والغربي نحن نتواصل مع حلفاءنا
في اوروبا وقد
شاركت في اجتماع في لندن وخلال مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن واكدنا على هذه التطورات وهذا
الدور الوحيد الذي تقومون به السيد الرئيس
الدور الذي تقوم به الولايات المتحده الذي
يثبت ان الروابط بين ضفه الاطلسي قويه
ومهمه
ورئيس الوزراء البولندي الذي هو رئيس
الحكومه لديه بين يديه مسؤوليه
شؤون الحكومه وفي عام 2025 سوف تكون
بولندا او تتولى الرئاسه دوريه للاتحاد
الاوروبي ونحن نرغب ان يتم تبني قرار في
الاتحاد الاوروبي بهذه المناسبه وان يتم
التركيز على تقويه
العلاقات بين ضفه الاطلس بين الولايات
المتحده واوروبا وان يكون هناك المزيد من
التعاون بين الشركاء بين اضفتي المحيط
الاطلسي هذه مساله بالغه الاهميه بنسبه
لنا لان الاوقات التي نمر بها في اوروبا
حاليا
بالغه الصعوب ودور الولايات المتحده دليل
صريح بان الشراكه مهمه لامن اوروبا
وتطورها المستقبلي
نحن في بولندا مررنا بالكثير من التجارب
في القرن الماضي لاسيما خلال مئه عام
الماضي السيد الرئيس مره اخرى نحن سعداء
واهلا وسهلا بكم سيدي
شكرا جزيلا على كرم الضيافه وحراره
الترحاب شكرا لكم على دعوه مجددا لزياره
ورسو في هذه الاوقات الحرجه ذكرت البابا
بولس واعتقد انك تتذكر القصه التي سردتها
عليك بشان يعض رفيع المستوى في مجلس الامن
القومي وكان هو اصغر الاعضاء سنا حيث كان
يبلغ اثنين وثلاثين عاما وكل ساعدت من
اوروبا
وكتبت تقرير
بولندا ستكون في غدوني
العام فطلب مني اعضاء المجلس عدم قراءه
هذا الخطاب
ولقيت اتصالا من البابا وقد كانت لدي ارى
متحفظه جديدا
وبعد انهاء الاتصال هاتفي
وهو طبعا لم يشر الى مساله الكاثوليك على
الاطلاق خلال ذلك الاتصال
الهاتفي بيننا
تحدثنا على امور
اثناء اللقاء الذي
كان بيننا
وقد قلت له اثناء الاستماع الذي جمعني به
لان هناك صوره
قال لي ايها السيناتور اليوم تحدثت اليك
كمواطن بولندي فخور بوطنه وليس بصفه الباب
اتذكر جيدا هذا الكلام الذي جمعنا
وقدرت بولندا العام الماضي
وقمت بزياره القاعده العسكريه التي بها
يتواجد الجنود الفولنديون والامريكيون
والحقيقه ان الولايات المتحده تحتاج
بولندا كما يحتاج بقدر ما تحتاج كولندا
للوطن المتحده وكذلك النيتو حتى نتمكن من
العمل في اي مكان في العالم ومسؤولياتنا
تتجاوز اوروبا الامن في اوروبا امر اساسي
وبسيطه
هذا التحالف قوي للغايه ربما هو التحالف
الاعظم في التاريخ المعاصر وفي التاريخ
بشكل عام اذا اوضحت بجلاه
ان التصريحات الولايات المتحده هي حقيقيه
تجاه الحلفاء
واكد ان النيت اقوى مما كان عليه على
الاطلاق وقلت لرئيس زيلينسكي عندما تحدثت
اليه في كير بالامس انني استطيع ان اقول
بكل فقر ان دعمنا لاوكرانيا سوف لن يتزعزع
وكذلك اكدت على ذلك اليوم
وكما نرى ان هناك ايضا طبعا سعي لي دخول
اعضاء جدد الى النيت
واعتقد نحن اذا
وصلنا النظر الى ما يجب التركيز عليه
سنكون في موضع موضع افضل من اي وقت مضى
اشكرك فخامه الرئيس على دعوكم لاوكرانيا
كان دعما استثنائي السيد الرئيس هذا حقيقه
عندما ياتي الاوكرانيون الى بلادكم عبر
الحدود هؤلاء
الاطفال والنساء وما تركوهم وراءهم من
ازواج
والاباء وامهات
هذا اثبت دعمكم
للاوكرانيين ونحن نؤكد مجددا
وقوفنا اتجاه امني اوروبا ونعمل على ضمان
ايضا
القياده
مقر قياده قواتنا في اوروبا سيكون موجودا
في بولندا كما اننا نطلق شراكه استراتيجيه
جديده مع خطط لبناء محطات الطاقه
لتعزيز امن الطاقه في بولندا لاجيال قادمه
السيد الرئيس
هناك رابط قويه بين الشعبين
البولندي والامريكي مزحته مع الرئيس وقلت
له عندما كنت شابا
كنت في
[موسيقى]
ضحيه يسكنها الايرلنديون وكان هناك منطقه
اسمها كلارموند في ولايه كان من يسكنها من
الطبقه العامله
وكنت على علم بمدى تاثير
الذهنيه البولنديه على هذه المنطقه
وقلت
للرئيس
مدى الفخر الذي
يشعر به
الامريكيون من اصول بولنديه
السيد الرئيس لو رايتم ذلك ينبغي ان تاتي
لتشاهد ذلك
بعينك انا اواثق انه مهما كانت تحديات
يمكن ان نواجهها معا بفضل شركتنا التي
تسمح لنا بالتصدر التحديات انا واثق لذلك
انا سعيد جدا
لعوده الى وارسو
وطبعا سنجري مناقشات بالتاكيد لن تحل كل
المشكلات ولكن بالتاكيد هذه علاقه مهمه
وحاسمه للولايات المتحده واشكركم جزيل
الشكر على تعاونكم ومساعدتكم
اذا استمعنا واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام
لجزء من هذه الجلسه الثنائيه التي جمعت
الرئيس البولندي بضيفه الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن عود مره اخرى الى الاستوديو والى
ضيفه هنا الساده العلوم السياسيه
والمستشار المركز الخليج للابحاث الدكتور
صالح القفلان هيكل الدكتور من جديد استمعت
الخطاب الرئيس
الحديث ايضا
ظهر اليوم
للرئيس بوتين في
البرلماني الروسي الى اين تتجه الامور
برايك بين المعسكر الغربي والشرقي هل نحن
امام تصعيد
كامل مشاكل ان التطورات خلال 24 ساعه
الماضيه تشير الى تصعيد سواء زياره الرئيس
بايدن الى كيف او حديث الرئيس بوتين وما
تضمنه في امام الجمعيه الفيدراليه
واليوم الحديث
يعني
الدعم المستمر والمتواصل بلا شك انه نحن
ندخل مرحله جديده من التصعيد وهذا يظهر من
خلال تاطير الطرفين لقضيه الصراع بوتين
يؤطر هذه القضيه ان هذه مؤامره وتحدي
دائما يكررها ويبنها مع لم تعد مجرد يعني
خطاب يعني يعني
لكسب الدعم يبدونها قناعه اصبحت راسخه
اننا نحن امام تهديد وجودي لروسي ان الغرب
لن يرتاح بدون تهديد تفكيك روسيا فهذه
الفكره هي يعني اصبحت هي يعني
موجهه
لبوتيل وقرارات ولذلك يعني من الصعب ان
انت تصور اي يعني تهد
الدراسات الدكتور صالح الخ